This is an F-16 fighter jet.
Since the 1970s, it's been
a cornerstone
of the US Air Force.
Now the US allows all these
militaries to also have F-16s.
And since Russia invaded
Ukraine in 2022...
Ukrainian President Volodymyr Zelenskyy
has been begging for them.
“Zelenskyy has been doubling down
on his request for...”
“...NATO jets...”
“...and they really are pleas
for fighter jets.”
But for Ukraine, the US
hasn't been as generous.
“You don't think he needs
F-16s now?”
“No, He doesn't need
F-16s now.”
And that might be surprising...
because the US has already given
nearly $47 billion
in military aid to Ukraine
over the past year.
That's a lot of weapons.
Far more than it gave even some
of its closest allies in 2020...
and more than four times
what it gave Afghanistan's army at the
height of the US-led war there.
This is a historic number that
you would see
typically the US military give to
another country over decades.
The U.S. refusing
to send F-16s
is a choice worth understanding...
because the weapons that the US has
and hasn't chosen to send Ukraine
and when they've sent them
have helped shape each phase
of this war.
So what has the US
been giving to Ukraine
and why?
Back in 2014
Russia took over Crimea and
parts of eastern Ukraine
with the help of Ukrainian
separatist fighters.
In 2014, ragtag wouldn't
even describe
the state of the Ukrainian
armed forces.
This is Jack Detsch — Foreign Policy’s
US  national security reporter.
They'd been gutted
by years of neglect.
A lot of the troops
didn't have uniforms.
Some of them didn't
have hot food.
Ukraine's leaders asked
the US for help
but President Barack Obama
only sent protective gear and supplies,
not weapons.
In 2018, President Donald trump agreed
to send a limited number of anti-tank
missiles called Javelins.
But the Ukrainian army was still
woefully unprepared
if Russia decided to escalate the conflict...
which it did.
In 2022, Russia launched a
full-scale invasion of Ukraine.
Russian jets and missiles
were doing immense damage
from the air...
and Russian tanks were pushing
Ukraine's troops backwards.
Ukraine again asked
the US for help.
From the beginning of the war
the Ukrainians wanted
a lot of the things
that you see on
the menu right now.
They wanted F-16s.
They wanted main
battle tanks.
They wanted this stuff
from the get-go.
President Joe Biden agreed to send
a large package of weapons
but it mainly included
the smaller
and relatively unsophisticated kinds.
The US sent more javelins,
plus ammunition, guns
and even some anti-aircraft missiles
called Stingers.
And many US allies sent similar
types of weapons.
Germany sent 1000 anti-tank missiles
and 500 stingers.
Belgium sent
2000 machine guns.
But no one sent their advanced
battle tanks or fighter jets.
The main question in the
beginning of the war
was not just what the US
was going to send.
I mean, the question was like,
are these guys going to fight?
Certainly that's been
a resounding yes.
Ukraine's soldiers used
anti-aircraft missiles
to prevent Russian aircraft
from controlling the skies.
And they used the guns, ammo,
and anti-tank weapons
to halt Russia's progress.
Like in this video, which shows
Ukrainian soldiers
destroying dozens of Russian tanks
approaching Kiev.
But even though the Ukrainians
were using these weapons well
the US hesitated to send it
more advanced equipment.
So the US
has been concerned at almost
every step about the potential
for Russia escalating
the conflict.
The US worried that Ukraine
might use
some of these advanced weapons
like fighter jets or long-range missiles
to strike inside Russia
sparking an escalation.
This concern would come to define
how the US supplied Ukraine.
In the spring of 2022, the war
entered its second phase.
Russia and Ukraine's armies weren't
moving as much anymore
and instead began pounding each other
with artillery.
Russia was firing a staggering
60,000 rounds a day...
while Ukraine could only manage
to fire around 6,000.
And it was quickly
running low.
But the US was still hesitating
to expand the scope of its support.
They're looking at what's
kind of on the Christmas
wish list
and deciding what's actually
prudent to give.
Finally, in April 2022
the US agreed to send Ukraine
its own artillery.
And like in the first phase of the war
a number of allies then sent
their own artillery...
even though some had
wanted to do it earlier.
You sort of saw folks in Europe
wanting the US to lead
but sometimes the US still
very much deep in deliberation mode.
The most important weapon the US
sent were called HIMARS...
powerful rocket launchers
that could hit targets
as far as 80 kilometers.
They weren't powerful enough
to strike inside Russia
but they did enable Ukraine to
hit Russian supply depots
and command posts far behind
its front lines...
which forced the Russians
to move them back
weakening its troops
at the front.
That's how Ukraine captured
the Kharkiv region
in September and the major city of Kherson
in November.
And by then, a new phase
was beginning.
In winter 2023, both sides were
planning new attacks.
Russia was gearing up
to push further into the Donetsk
and Luhansk regions.
But Ukraine also wanted
to take back territory...
particularly in the south.
In order to do this
Ukraine would need to
move troops quickly
which requires armored vehicles
like tanks...
something it had been asking for
for months.
Some countries had sent
older models of tanks...
but just like with artillery,
the US waited.
They wanted the Germans
to act first
by sending Leopard battle tanks.
The Germans...
were waiting for
the United States
to give them some political
top cover here.
A little bit of
a game of chicken.
Finally, in January 2023
the UK and then the US agreed
to send their advanced tanks...
prompting Germany and
several allies to follow
with their best battle tanks.
Just like with anti-tank missiles
and HIMARS before
the US and its allies
were hoping that
these tanks can push Ukraine
to win
some decisive victories
in this phase...
which is where we are now.
If the Ukrainians kind of
can't turn the tide
turn the balance right now
it's going to be tricky
to see how this doesn't go into
an extended stalemate.
That's why Ukraine is still
asking for fighter jets.
F-16s could protect Ukraine's tanks
from Russian aircraft...
making their attack
much more powerful.
Ukraine has also
been asking the US
for a long range missiles
called ATACMS
which it could use to strike Russian positions as far as
300 kilometers behind their lines.
Already, a few allies are in favor of
sending these weapons.
But as of this video
the US is hesitating over
familiar concerns.
Questions about their readiness
for training on those.
Also, of course, you know,
just the question again...
how far are the Ukrainians
going to fire these things?
So far, none of the decisions
to send any of these weapons
has inspired Russia to escalate.
And in March, Poland
and Slovakia
agreed to send some of their
older fighter jets
making the eventual
approval of F-16s
or long range missiles
more of a possibility.
But after giving Ukraine over
$46 billion in military aid
public opinion in the US
is changing.
A recent Pew Research poll showed
the proportion of people who believe the US
has sent too much aid to Ukraine has grown
particularly on the right.
Biden, facing a lot of pressure
not only within his party,
but, of course
from Republican rivals getting ready
for the 2024 debate stage.
That's going to make it much more difficult
for President Biden
to sustain this clip.
And even if Biden maintains
popular support to send weapons
he might not have enough.
A recent analysis found that certain supplies
may be approaching the minimal level
that the US requires for
its own war planning.
It's why the US is now focusing on ways
to increase production of weapons
at home
in allied countries
and in Ukraine.
But just building those plants
could take years.
One year of US and allied support
has helped transform
the Ukrainian army
into a formidable force
whose soldiers have repeatedly held
its ground against a much larger
Russian army.
But with both the battlefield and
US politics changing
the questions now are how well
is Ukraine going to fight
with what they have
and how much more US help can they count on?
Thanks for watching this episode
of Vox Atlas.
Vox has been covering the war
in Ukraine since it began
with in-depth explainers and analysis.
You can find all our coverage
of the war at Vox.com/Ukraine.